on ne change pas les rayures de m ce
dicton bien connu est de moins en moins
vrai
en 2019 ce petit hébron attiré
l'attention de la planète avec son
pelage noir tacheté de blanc
nez dans la réserve du masaï mara au
kenya le zébron prénommé tir à vie avec
une condition appelé pseudo mélanie sme
ce lundi qu'une anomalie dans la
production de mélanine le pigment qui
donne aux zèbres ses rayures et ira
n'est pas le seul à travers l'afrique on
voit de plus en plus des bons avec un
pelage atypique
des chercheurs californiens ont voulu
comprendre pourquoi à l'aide de dar de
bioxyde ils ont recueilli des
échantillons d'adn et n 240 nombre des
plaines
les chercheurs ont fait leur collecte à
travers neuf régions les parties dans
l'est et le sud de l'afrique
parmi les arbres étudier cette avait des
plages atypique leur adn révèle un plus
haut taux de consanguinité que ceux avec
des rayures normal
cela indique que les zébrures atypiques
sont dus à des gènes récessifs ceux ci
s'exprime seulement quand les deux
parents transmettre la même version du
gène
les parents consanguins ont un bagage
génétique similaire
l'augmentation de zèbres aux motifs
atypique signifie donc qu'il ya plus de
reproduction consanguine
mais comment l'expliquer
les zèbres des peines migrent
habituellement sur de grandes distances
et différentes populations se mélangent
et se reproduisent entre elles
mais la pose de clôtures la construction
de routes et le développement henin ont
fragmenté leur habitat
cela limite donc le mélange des
populations de zèbres et par conséquent
le brassage génétique est essentielle à
la survie de l'espèce
la naissance de zèbres comment tu iras
indique que l'espèce devient plus
vulnérable
le fait que les arbres perdent de
rayures et donc un signe qu'ils perdent
du terrain